that's I want before I forget what the
[ __ ] happened with 10-minute podcasts oh
we're giving it away you're giving your
pot we're giving the podcast away we are
giving the iTunes channel the website
the you know the Twitter for what it's
worth but the point is though to a guy
named Mark Evans who is market shout-out
to my guy shout out to Mark Evans Mark
Evans and why on Twitter he's an editor
who lives on the east coast of the show
yeah he's a big fan of the show and we
sort of ran a contest and we just
started like airing people's stuff
basically what happened is you know like
the first was three years of the show
was Brian Cowen Chris D'Elia and myself
and at which point we just became too
much of a everyone was so busy and you
know Brian lives way out and Chris
doesn't get a trade yeah what's that
both betrayed you know they did not
betray it was a betrayal let me tell you
something what happened got less and
less interested no this is what happened
or what happened Bobby said in did a
bunch of them I get a bunch yeah and I'm
and I'm friends with both guys but I'm
gonna say this right friends with
Shakespearean betrayal I know wasn't I I
made the final call and said guys
because you're the only one that's real
oh really all right let me just your
foundation starting to see a theme here
it's not Jordan didn't [ __ ] dick -
yeah
no it's cool if you like come on you
don't have to agree with me okay this is
what I'm wittich I'm gonna tell a story
okay okay telescope a a little story
right and and you see if I'm you know
vaguely correct alright yeah here's the
story a long time ago many years ago
right there was a guy named Will Sasso
okay he's not fat he's thick thank you
it's a true story so big dick will
that's what everyone calls everybody man
yeah yeah well sticker fish dicks right
and he knew a guy by the name of Italian
guy right Chris D'Elia
and right not on the Galleon he's not
Italian ice half he's a battalion a half
Italian he's got the Italian right and a
kind of good-looking intrinsically funny
guy by the name of Bryan Callen who used
to work for my dad and that's how you
kind of know him to write the beginning
right and at that time there our careers
were okay they're they're coming up you
know Bryan's rebuilding had his own
podcast and he decides to you just we're
[ __ ] what are you talking about it
but no not you I mean come on alia was
coming up oh yeah before Whitney right
when did that happen before Whitney yeah
so he was calm wouldn't happen right
away while we were doing the podcast
exactly 2112 I understand I'm just gonna
tell you I'm paving a story all right
doesn't matter guys will come up to me
and I'll go no they're not gonna listen
to this that's that's all they do
[ __ ]
they don't [ __ ] let's do it that's
another lie in your [ __ ] story time
story time story time tell the story
alright I'll just point out the
inaccuracies while you're having a
breather Chris is doing well and [ __ ]
all doing my stand-up and doing great
right Brian a bit around forever he's
the best best yeah okay
they both of their family oh you're
trying to say that with my story friend
all right story time with Bob still okay
all right you know he's serious when he
calls himself Bob when he's actually
pissed story time Bob yeah let me get my
[ __ ] bearings they do a podcast they
decided to come up with a [ __ ] theme
10-minute podcast right yeah how could
it go wrong
Will Sasso Bryan Callen D'Elia doing one
podcast and it was a success people love
it
three of probably one of the funniest
people on planet earth together doing a
I mean imagine this is pre fighter in
the kid this is pre D'Elia
congrat who he is right and it's [ __ ]
it's like the Traveling Wilburys yes the
Traveling Wilburys alright but this is
what happened yeah then they start
giving gifts getting gifts getting gifts
yeah yes
gifts gifts like gif no gifts get it for
the TST a difference okay so how about
this what do we do this don't ever [ __ ]
don't correct me helping it you're not a
painter alright so Roy Orbison guys
years ago did he die when they were
touring as a traveling woman I think
they were just [ __ ] around when they
could
yeah just like 10-minute podcast we're
[ __ ] around when we could and when
things got a little was they started
getting they started getting [ __ ] no I'm
can I just finish my usual story and
then all of a sudden what happens they
abandon Will Sasso be abandoned you my
friend let me finish all right so you're
looking like the you know what I like I
like the uncomfortable spaces yeah how
about this friend okay I'm being real
and I'm trying to be legit right now
okay and I'm not downplaying Chris
D'Elia I think he is he everything that
these two get they deserve
they're so [ __ ] funny two of the
funniest [ __ ] guys ruff funniest guys
nicest [ __ ] there I really consider them
true friends yes and you too yes I love
them yeah I mean like if they died it
would be so devastating to me it would
be like rare but alright alright okay
[ __ ] betrayed you know they got to
the boat 200 meters out yeah I looked at
their billion dollars yeah yeah okay we
didn't betray and then all of a sudden
I'm gonna ask you this my friend yeah
this guy is gonna take what do you think
ten minute podcast people were listening
because of you Brian and [ __ ] Dahlia
here's why we like Mark Evans because
mark what he does is and I should say
over the past two and a half like three
years well first my buddy Tommy blotches
started doing a bunch of stuff with me
Tommy's a writer producer uh-huh you'd
be familiar with a lot of the stuff that
he's done big fan
yeah and then he wrote on like the early
he wrote on like the first years of like
Late Night with Conan O'Brien right and
the great job Ali G show he created that
show Metalocalypse you know that I have
it on blu-ray okay and
you know a bunch of other stuff and you
know he does all that's 20 things and
then my good buddy Chad Kultgen of
albums written I have Yellowstone and
National Park I have you got Duncan
pride yeah oh that's a great outfit with
a double album Duncan Brian yeah don't
get proud remember the remember the
track remember the donut donut we are
dug it to my knurled don't forget mine
mineral Tallahassee nut yeah ocean holes
sort of turned into a very different
podcast weird and then what we did was
we sort of started this thing called the
diamond ding we realized that we want to
like like you know like like the like
prehistoric vegetations
spinning turning into coal pressing down
and creating a diamond you know we want
I know how [ __ ] diamonds made you
[ __ ] want to take our audience and
squish it down until there's one diamond
left yeah essentially over the past year
we've lost all our sponsors our audience
has completely dropped off to where we
only have we've done it on purpose to
show got more and more inside the jokes
are impossible to get unless you've
listened to everything yeah a lot of
references to wrestling a lot of stuff a
lot of useless [ __ ] and we've had a
wonderful time pairing off our wonderful
audience to where now all we have left
is diamond listeners okay and from how
many listeners are there how many
listeners right now remember the
Canadian math okay 140 people it might
be a little more than that I'm not sure
I'm not gonna map them from Canada right
I'm stupid okay so yeah thousands and
thousands less than used to
and so now basically what we did was we
listened to all these submissions from
people like Bob look at City that's what
that's what oh it's a [ __ ] closed its
that closed circuit city by the taco on
Sunset yeah that's what it used to have
used to be Best Buy and now yes we used
to be a Best Buy back when people were
[ __ ] buying DVDs and CDs and now
we're the Circuit City
that's boarded up and his tagged gang
tags and [ __ ] Halland teamed up with
that other guy with Brenda and he
betrayed you
no he did not betray me [ __ ] so what
we're doing is we're giving it to Marley
ins of dollars he's an editor in making
he cuts together old [ __ ] you don't even
see it what do you mean dog do they have
a successful cottage industry they've
put together
Brendan is a workhorse he's a very
competitive guy he's an athlete so as
Brett as Brett as Brian has described
like this guy got his hands on something
and it's gone crazy
they make [ __ ] t-shirts I've made one
t-shirt in the past four years talk
about t-shirts well by the way kind of
busy you know acting in France sort of
my day job that is true you know you
work it you have their work yeah but
then it's like you know there's a lot of
things where it's like oh I'm trying to
get my thing popped off I want to do
this I want to make that where you're
writing this you're doing that right
right and then you don't and then that
doesn't end nothing I want then but then
a show says yeah all right yeah it's a
TV sure sure excuse me and I have a
message to tiger belly fans right now
this show tiger belly don't I'm not
Bobby and kalila know this show right
here will never be paid off not diamond
yeah we're gonna have nude no no no no
diamonds right we are every week and
it'd be religious about love giving you
content I love it all right yeah and
would there's no betrayal here I love it
George is not gonna stab me in the back
like some people that I know right this
might what's your name again what Jason
thinlit is literally behind you sitting
in the closet right behind it just
blowing anybody in this unit look Bobby
listen kalila
I think that's wonderful I think that's
what a podcast is about
we are in the age of content we've had I
don't mind saying a pretty funny
conversation thus far there's a lot of
irreverent people talking in a room of
their house and the podcasting landscape
right but this conversation has been
pretty good hmm and that's what podcast
should be and a 10-minute podcast we've
completely betrayed that first of all
it's only 10 minutes to begin with so
that's dumb and then and now we're just
giving it away but yes like a like like
a like a like a mystique painted Orca
breaching yeah itself yeah in the in the
waters of South Africa yeah can anybody
name the songs from that band I named
earlier any of the yeah in holes of
ocean else is one poses one donut dan
was it donut Dan yes it was a beaver
something mineral yeah what do you think
I should do do you think cuz we here's
what we decided yeah we're gonna stop
doing the podcast and then maybe in a
year we'll come out with a new podcast
III honestly believe this I honestly
believe this I believe that you should
always have be on a podcast I believe
that will sasso because you have the
equipment right I have I'll be honest
with you - is that your podcast is one
of the reasons why I have this podcast
everything influences me right so the
DVD essay influenced me a lot but also
right around the dot at that time I
remember going to your house with Cal
and Angelia there yeah and doing being a
guest on your 10 minute person and it
was super fun
and it gave me what planted planted the
seed yeah and so you're so funny and
your characters are so good I think
there is it would be criminal for you
not to be on that format I don't think
that I think I honestly feel like
there's a huge glut of them on the
internet and I think you I
think that there I think that it's
really hard to strike I think it's
really hard to know hit paydirt
nope no no I should just be I mean
listen listen we're not on the house all
the time do we make this right we have
yeah sponsors right yeah we have
sponsors it also an argon we're making
less than Mark Evans inherit he gets the
iTunes channel so immediately everyone
that is subscribed to the 10-minute
podcast is subscribed to the Mark Evans
Tim in a pod
he's he's a very handy guy with all of
his Photoshop and editing and After
Effects but I've decided I'm gonna
design an avatar for for the podcast
maybe I'll hang on to it for a little
while I don't know to keep the name he
keeps the name yeah it keeps the he has
the website the domain
he gets the Twitter the stupid Facebook
all the things that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about he will get those and I and yeah
and I don't know yeah you know I got a
really nice message from someone today
I'm gonna get real how about this Bobby
I'm listening to you
okay that's why I close my eyes I'm
listening okay I got a very nice message
today on Instagram messenger right from
a young man who said he'd been living
listening to the show from the age of 13
now he's 19 years old and he said it's
really shaped my sense of humor blah
blah blah he said a lot of really nice
things and he was really I I wrote him
back you know you try to write these
people back when they say something when
they just you know when they share that
hey you've done this thing and I've
listened to it and here's how it's
affected me I think a small percentage
of people are obviously reaching out so
it's important to go to you know thank
the guy for doing that for sharing and
for reaching
[Music]